hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing one of the
most feared curses in The Wizarding
World Avada cadaver also known as the
killing curse specifically we're going
to be taking a look at where it came
from who created it why it's
unforgivable why it may be merciful and
what the very surprising function of
this spell may have once been let's get
into it history the list of victims
who've been struck down by the infamous
killing curse is seemingly endless and
one of the biggest proponents of this
vicious spell is unsurprisingly Lord
Voldemort but even though Lord
Voldemort's name has become somewhat
synonymous with this horrible curse the
spell itself dates back many centuries
before Voldemort's time in fact records
indicate that the curse was invented as
early as the Middle Ages sometime
between the 5th and 15th century given
that this time period was Rife with
conflict between wizard kind and Uncle
kind I'd imagine that it was originally
created as a weapon to be used against
Muggles though this is of course just my
own speculation the curse itself is
generated by uttering the incantation of
Vada cadavera which then creates a
blindingly intense green bolt of light
capable of instantly killing a victim
upon impact the spell serves a simple
purpose it puts an end to the victim's
life in a time of struggle this would
have been the perfect solution for
wizards to gain the upper hand over
Muggles and for many centuries this
spell could be freely used by The
Wizarding population however in the year
1717 Avada Kedavra was outlawed and
deemed unforgivable by the ministry of
magic alongside two other cursors crucio
the torture curse and imperio the Mind
Control curse all three curses were
created in the Middle Ages they have a
suspicion that all three may have been
created by the same unnamed dark wizard
these curses were deemed unforgivable
because of their sadistic nature and the
general consensus among wizard kind was
that these spells were too powerful and
cruel to be used freely in The Wizarding
World the capacity to torture people
control them against their will and kill
them with a single incantation was just
not something that could be left
unrecognized or unpunishable in society
when legislation was passed by the
ministry to name these three curses
unforgivable the strictest penalties
were put in place and attached to their
use utilizing one of these three curses
just one time could land you a life
sentence to Azkaban it remains unclear
to this day why exactly these three
spells were singled out named
unforgivable when there are so many
horrible curses in The Wizarding World
but I imagine there must have been some
sort of a catalyst elik Camp was the
minister for magic at the time the
Spells were outlawed with just one year
left in his term I like to think that
something may have happened involving
these spells that threatened his
position I can only imagine the chaos
that something like the imperious curse
would cause in a government structure
like the ministry of magic and so I can
hardly blame gamp for outlawing these
curses alternatively perhaps it was just
a politically driven decision in order
to secure the popular vote Avada cadaver
remains an unforgivable curse to this
day but it certainly hasn't stopped dark
Wizards across the globe from utilizing
it in all of their darker Deeds before
we move on from the early history of the
curse however I want to Enlighten you
with a theory about how Avada cadaver
may have been created and for what
purpose now it's certainly no surprise
that Ivana cadavra closely resembles the
stereotypical magical words Abracadabra
which we often hear magicians declare
when they do things like pull bunnies
out of ads JK Rowling even admitted
herself that this similarity was
intentional in the Middle Ages people
believed that any event they couldn't
logically explain was likely caused by
Magic this led to much of the population
of medieval Europe deeply faring having
an enchantment cast on them in response
to this they began using the words
Abracadabra to ward off any potential
wrongdoing sent in their Direction the
Therian question suggests that Avada
godavara is derived from Abracadabra and
was originally created to heal the words
Abracadabra in the Aramaic language the
language spoken by the ancient amerians
roughly translates to let the thing be
destroyed but there is sub suggested
that the spell was originally created to
kill viruses and bacteria not people but
that once was it kind discovered its
capabilities its true path of death and
destruction began given that the Middle
Ages were a time of plague and illness
perhaps this Theory does bear some
weight I'd also like to mention that one
of the most famous dark witches of all
time existed in this time period a witch
by the name of Morgana lafaye the
Nemesis of Merlin provided that Morgana
was a dark witch she was unsurprisingly
a master of the dark arts however she
also happened to be particularly gifted
at performing Magic on the other side of
the spectrum known for her ability to
cast advanced healing magic perhaps she
is the Spell's original Creator why is
it unforgivable the differences between
the three established curses deemed
unfigurable and all of the other
horrific curses in The Wizarding World
is a line that's been left entirely
unclear with spells out there like
transmography and torture which is
perfectly all right to use by the way
it's hard to imagine why these three
curses would be singled out however my
theory is this the three unforgivable
curses have one thing in common no
counter curse even the darkest of spells
like sectum sempra have a counter curse
but in the case of Avada Kedavra crucio
and imperio there's not much you can do
if they're cast at you there probably
are of the dark spells that you can't
deflect but I think it's the combination
of their Sinister nature propensity to
do damage and unavoidability that make
them truly unforgivable how it kills you
given that Vada cadaver leaves almost no
trace of being used on its victims we're
somewhat left in the dark with regards
to how it kills you there are two
predominant theories on this topic the
first Theory suggests that the curse
causes all the victims internal organs
to immediately stop functioning this is
more of a physical death and the second
theory claims that the soul of the
victim is magically ripped from their
body more of an ethereal death as it
happens I've actually made a full-length
video discussing this topic which
provides evidence for both sides of the
argument as I've already covered it I'll
leave you with these two options and if
if you want to learn more then head over
to my video how Avada Kedavra kills you
is it merciful in Harry Potter there are
plenty of spells and curses that have
the potential to kill someone bombard a
Maxima fiend fire sectum sempra can
fringo all of these bear the capacity to
kill a Target and more so what makes
Avada Kedavra different because there's
no confirmed explanation as to how Avada
Kedavra actually kills you this is a bit
hard to answer but what I want to hone
in on is the fact that it kills you
instantly the counterpart to this type
of death in the Muggle world would be
lethal
injection which is often considered
Humane in the right context like when an
injured animal has no chance of survival
this method of killing someone ends a
life with seemingly the least suffering
possible given that something like
bombardo Maxima would horrifically blow
your body to Pieces is it possible that
Avada Kedavra is actually somewhat
merciful I think that the answer to this
is dependent on which Theory you
subscribe to when it comes to how the
spell kills you if you believe that
advada cadavra physically Kills You by
stopping your organs then perhaps this
spell is more merciful than we give it
credit for however if you subscribe to
the belief that Avada Kedavra forcefully
snaps your soul out of your body then I
think this method of dying is undeniably
more Sinister and that's it for this
video is there any other component of
Avada cadaver that you want covered
leave a comment down below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]